wir schauen in die ukraine meine damen
und herren die humanitäre situation in
mariupol und dem stahlwerk dort ist
weiterhin katastrophal ein weiterer
versuch eingekesselten zivilisten
herauszuholen ist gescheitert das an der
verteidigung des stahlwerks beteiligte
asaf regiment erklärte am abend im
messenger dienst telegramm russland habe
dem beschuss des werksgeländes wieder
aufgenommen beschossen würden auch
gebäude in denen sich zivilisten
aufhielten
am montagabend haben nach ukrainischen
angaben 23 zivilisten das belagerte
stahlwerk verlassen können ukraine
präsident selent ski gibt aber dennoch
nicht auf
wir tun weiterhin alles um die
verbliebenen zivilisten in mario pohl zu
retten die evakuierungsaktion geht
weiter morgen erwarten wir auch
humanitäre korridore in weiteren städten
die brillianz und was sie lifka die
streitkräfte der ukraine während die
vormarsch versuche der besatzer
heldenhaft ab im süden des landes im dom
bass überall bleibt die lage äußerst
schwierig aber ich bin jedem einzelnen
unserer verteidiger dankbar denn die
stellung
gleichzeitig erreichen uns aber auch
diese bilder der sturm auf das stahlwerk
hat offenbar begonnen bei den jüngsten
russischen angriffen seien auch zwei
zivilisten getötet worden von russischer
seite gab es zunächst keine offizielle
bestätigung die staatliche
nachrichtenagentur ria nowosti meldete
zuvor jedoch dass luftangriffe gegen die
asa auf kämpfer dort liefen und
veröffentlichte auch dieses twitter
video wie gesagt dort sind nicht nur
kämpfer sondern auch zivilisten und auch
der vize kommandeur des us regierung den
sturm auf das stahlwerk
ukraine 2008 haben marine und infanterie
mit artillerie das auf stahlwerk
erschossen auch fliegerbomben wurden
abgeworfen sondern wie eine bombe und
was nur zwei zivilisten wurden bei
diesem angriff getötet in diesem moment
versuchen tranzer bewaffnete fahrzeuge
und eine große zahl von soldaten mit
hilfe von schiffen an land zu kommen
wir tun alles um diese angriffe
abzuwehren
also die situation wird immer
dramatischer gehen wir in die ukraine
nach sapporo wo unser reporter philipp
peter fiszter philipp ja die wenigen
flüchtlinge die es geschafft haben raus
aus diesem stahlwerk die säulen bei dir
in sapporo sie ankommen ist das schon
der fall und wenn ja was sagen sie dir
ja sie sind vor etwa anderthalb stunden
angekommen insgesamt 150 zivilisten
konnten gerettet werden aus dem
stahlwerk in mariupol sie sind hier in
der branche auf diesem parkplatz wo ich
jetzt gerade stehe angekommen hinter mir
in diesem zelt wurden sie erst mal mit
dem nötigsten versorgt haben einen
schluck wasser bekommen haben etwas zu
essen bekommt und ja jetzt sind sie in
sicherheit manche waren zwei monate in
dieser hölle manche haben zwei monate
lang das sonnenlicht nicht gesehen haben
sich und den russischen raketen und
bomben einfach nur in den bunkern des
stahlwerks versteckt haben jetzt eine
fast 48 stündige evakuierungs reise
hinter sich sie mussten 26 russische
kontroll posten passieren an fast allen
wurden die männer ausgezogen nach
irgendwelchen tattoos abgesucht aber das
hatte natürlich alles nur ein zweck man
wollte die menschen so lange wie es nur
geht erniedrigen aber sie haben es jetzt
geschafft und sie sind wahnsinnig
glücklich wahnsinnig dankbar und viele
von ihnen sind einfach nur sprachlos
darüber dass sie diese hölle endlich
überstanden haben dass sie das alles
überlebt haben das gibt die gelegenheit
ja auch an informationen zu bekommen zu
kommen wie die situation tatsächlich
leben stahlwerk dort aussieht hattest du
die chance verdient zu sprechen gibt es
solche informationen aktuell
ja die menschen bestätigen alles was wir
in den vergangenen tagen berichtet haben
was wir von soldaten die im stahlwerk
sind gehört haben es gibt sehr wenig
wasser und sehr wenige nahrungsmittel
also die menschen haben sich einmal am
tag ernährt haben sehr wenig wasser
getrunken und konnten nicht fliehen es
gibt ja russische propaganda die
behauptet dass ukrainische soldaten oder
mitglieder des oft regiments die
menschen dort gefangen gehalten haben
also dass sie die menschen nicht haben
gehen lassen das haben uns alle
flüchtlinge mit den wir sprechen konnten
natürlich widerlegt sie haben gesagt das
stimmt nicht wir wollten raus und die
soldaten haben mehrfach versucht uns
raus zu bringen aber jedes mal wenn wir
fliehen wollten begann die russischen
luft- und raketenangriffe und wir
konnten einfach nicht weg nun gibt es
meldungen ich habe es vorhin gesagt
wonach eine jahr erneut großer angriff
auf das stahlwerk begonnen hat wie wird
es dort weitergehen welche chance haben
die die noch da sind
ja jetzt gerade läuft dieser großangriff
putin hatte ja eigentlich vor einiger
zeit gesagt dass es nicht zum sturm auf
das stahlwerk kommen soll das stimmt
ganz offensichtlich nicht die russen
versuchen das stahlwerk jetzt gerade
einzunehmen die ukraine leisten
weiterhin erbitterten
widerstand ja und wie es weitergeht ist
völlig unklar auf jeden fall muss man
sagen es ist mit dem schlimmsten zu
rechnen sowohl für die zivilisten die
noch da sind aber auch natürlich für die
soldaten denn einige der familien mit
denen wir heute sprechen konnten haben
doch immer angehörige dort denn viele
männer viele väter sind kämpfer wir sind
gehören dem us aufträge mehr an oder der
regulären ukrainischen armee die sind
weiterhin in diesem stall der viele
familien die hier ankamen haben gesagt
wir haben überlebt und wir sind dafür
wahnsinnig dankbar dass zivilisten
gerettet werden aber unsere väter unsere
ehemänner unsere brüder sind weiterhin
da wenn sie nicht gerettet werden dann
werden sie dort entweder vom band oder
sie werden von putins bomben ermordet
philipp hat auf ausbrüche wo er heute
über 100 flüchtlinge angekommen sind aus
den stahlwerken mario pohl danke philipp